[Music]
welcome back
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin will be sentenced for the murder
of george floyd next month
anthony levy shows us why the
prosecution wants a harsher sentence
while shoving's team says
the law doesn't allow for it the
sentencing of derek shovin is really the
last big battle to be fought at the
trial court level
and it's no surprise that the
prosecution and the defense
want different things in minnesota
sentences are determined by guidelines
that take into account a defendant's
criminal history
chauvin doesn't have a record so under
the guidelines he would be sentenced to
150 months which is 12 and a half years
but prosecutors want a sentence that
exceeds the guideline
it's called an upward departure they
want possibly as long as 40 years
the judge has the discretion to depart
upward to give a greater sentence
although he does not have to judge peter
cahill will decide whether aggravating
factors existed in this case that would
allow for an upward departure
prosecutors say those factors are george
floyd being particularly vulnerable
they claim that floyd was treated with
particular cruelty and that chauvin
abused his position of authority
the prosecutors go on to say that the
crime was committed
with three or more people and happened
in the presence of children
meanwhile chauvin's attorney argues
against a greater sentence
he says floyd was not particularly
vulnerable because of his size
eric nelson says abuse of a position of
authority is not a recognized
aggravating factor in minnesota
he also says the other defendants
haven't been convicted
and the state has not proven the three
other officers intentionally aided
chauvin in a crime
he also notes the children walking by
and stopping to witness the arrest
is not sufficient grounds for an upward
departure not only would the conviction
itself
be um reviewed by by a court of appeals
uh but if cahill does depart upward and
give a greater sense
that would also be an issue on appeal
derek chovin is scheduled to be
sentenced on june 25th
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
and be sure to tune in to the law and
crime network this friday
for an hour-long special on the derek
shoven trial hosted by angenette levy
and thank you for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you